city of chicago press
thank you peter
next on book tv at the tenement museum
in new york city louisa thomas recounts
the life of her great grandfather norman
thomas and his three brothers during
world war one
louisa thomas is of course the great
granddaughter of norman thomas
who ran for president in six consecutive
elect elections on the socialist ticket
prior to his entry into politics he was
a protestant clergyman and as louisa
explains he often worked in the tenement
houses of immigrant families while his
focus was on was often in east harlem
his experience may have been very
similar had his focus been the lower
east side norman thomas dreamed of
creating an integrated harmonious new
york not entirely broken down by race
and nationality i imagine he would have
been heartened by the families who lived
in our tenement across the street we
have a recording of a sicilian catholic
woman josephine balditzy who remembers
that as a girl she lived next door to a
lithuanian jewish family the rogozewskis
on the sabbath she recalls mrs
robaszewski would call for young
josephine to turn the light on for her
60 years later you could still hear the
pride in her voice for being called upon
for that task
it is entirely probable that families
living in our tenement which was open
until the year 1935 discussed or admired
norman thomas tonight we're very pleased
to discuss his life and work with louisa
thomas the author of conscience she will
be signing copies of the book after the
talk and keep in mind that when you buy
a copy of the featured book at tenement
talks you are supporting the author the
publisher and our museum if you choose
to become a museum member this evening
we will give you a complimentary copy of
conscience
tonight's conversation is led by john
meacham executive editor and executive
vice president at random house a former
editor of newsweek and a pulitzer
prize-winning author and commentator on
politics history and religious faith in
america he is editor editor-at-large at
wnet public media and contributor to the
pbs television news magazine need to
know
after their conversation you'll have the
opportunity to ask questions and since
we're recording tonight's presentation
on book tv you'll have to ask your
questions from the microphone right here
we won't be able to accept questions
from your seat but now please join me in
welcoming our guests
[Applause]
thank you all very much uh thank you to
the tenement museum which has in a
relatively short time become such an
important part of the fabric of the city
you hear a lot about it even in the
american south uh where i come from and
they actually
are struck that not everything is a
tenement uh
but and so they can come and look and
see what it what it used to be like but
uh thank you for your your hospitality
and congratulations to louisa who has
written
i think a wonderful book
a deeply researched and
engagingly written account of
her own family which is not always an
easy thing to do
and i want to start with
some specific questions and then um
we're going to read a couple of things
then there'll be a little socialist
jeopardy to keep her
keeper going
but we'll start with
why this book now
well this book is
as you mentioned a family story but it's
also a story about
an american family and a time at war and
a time when the country was going
through some
major um cultural political economic and
social upheaval
um
you know the country looked very
different than it did
a hundred years ago than it did today
but it looked more like it does today
you know at the end of world war one
than it did at the beginning um
during the war
when world war one began most americans
uh the extent of most americans contact
with federal government was going to the
post office
um
four years later that's the big 1914 you
know
1917 happens the united states enters
the war suddenly millions of men are
being drafted
um
millions of men
see their government working in it and
women too see their government in a much
different light
and they were forced to reckon with
questions about
what a citizen's obligation to his
country is
what a brother's obligation is to
another brother
what you know sons and daughters
obligations to their parents are in a
way that they just hadn't you know 20
years before
um
of course these questions didn't just
arise you know on a day um
they were planted in the in the
few decades that had come before um
you know i think it's hard for us to
realize
just
how
striking were the changes um in the
beginning of the 20th century but
at the same time you know we face these
questions all the time i mean we are
also a country at war um we are also
debating these questions of
you know to what extent should we be
committing our resources and our
citizens lives and our
um our money and our and our time and
our faith um
not only to the government but
to our fellow citizens and um
you know so i think these are perennial
questions
and the way because
the the
change was so extreme and that the kind
of transition was so violent
literally and figuratively
um they had to reckon with these
questions in a way that i think really
brought them to the fore and in looking
at the way that they did that i think
that
we can see you know how these questions
still
um
still live in our own lives
so when you when you think about the era
really from
tr through wilson so it started the turn
of the century
ever more rapid industrialization
a nascent progressive movement that
gives us the social legislation that
is ratified and increased by the new
deal and endures
uh in some form until un unto this hour
you have as you say a selective service
system
that actually engaged the broad
population when conflict came up
would you say that
that might be the most striking
difference in terms of the issue that
got all the all four of these brothers
involved
it was not as though
today
we get to choose whether or not we're
interested in serving
then it was not so much a choice and you
were confronted much more directly with
a conscientious decision do you fight do
you not fight do you find alternative
ways to serve is the cause just
do you think that
these brothers given some other choice
if they'd been sort of out of the
context would have dealt with the same
issues
um i think that you know that's an
excellent question i think that um
the fact that the draft did exist in
that time
was
certainly something that
forced the brothers to reckon with
reckon with the conflict in a way that
most young people just simply do not
have to
um
today yeah i mean i
never i mean i've never once
um wondered if i was going to have to go
to war for my country you know and i was
born well after vietnam i mean it's just
not something that has ever crossed my
mind um
i think that they saw that
war was very real and it required a kind
of
engagement and commitment
um
uh
that surpassed even you know what they
had to do or didn't have to do norman
thomas for example didn't actually have
to fight he was older than the draft age
he was a clergyman which would have also
made him exempt he had a large family
that was dependent on him um
he didn't have to engage in some sort of
process
that tested you know
whether or not you know this country
should be doing what it was doing um he
chose to
um and
but he chose to because so many people
didn't have the choice
um
and he thought
that there was something something odd
about that i mean even the phrase
selective service there's actually an
interesting story behind the decision to
call it the selective service
um
when the united states went to war there
was some debate over um whether or not
there would be a draft at all there was
actually some debate over whether or not
they would send soldiers to europe i
mean there's this amazing story even
after the the war declaration when um a
congressman is you know
some military officers testifying before
congress on you know what resources
they're going to have to command and
um
and then you know he says well of course
we'll need soldiers and the congressman
goes my god you're not going to send
soldiers to you are you and
nobody corrected him
you know and as late as mid-april you
know weeks after the declaration of war
there were passing you know the armed
service committee was passing um
in 17 i'm sorry um
you know
was talking about was rejecting the
draft as a measure
um
there was a man named george creel who
was a journalist um
who wilson
he was one of the first people wilson
called
um
after his the decision to go to war and
he set up
an organization called the um committee
on public information
and it was basically a propaganda arm he
was brilliant
you know he was that doesn't sound like
one
and you know
one of the things that he suggested
doing was calling it
selective service
because
selective you know appeals to the kind
of sense of elite it's a suggested
choice
service you know suggests sacrifice
um you know they didn't want to call it
conscription
um and
wilson actually gave a speech early on
you know when he
announced the draft and he said this is
in no way um this is no way a
conscription of the unwilling it is
rather um
i think i don't remember the exact
phrase but is rather you know
the decision of people who have
volunteered and mass
right
this act actually happened in the
british too which you know had a
traditional nose conscription and when
they decided to implement the draft um
they put up posters said you have three
choice you can enlist you can join a
group which will be called up later
or
you will be deemed to have him
you will be deemed to have enlisted
they'll always be in england
let's talk about the brothers uh put
them in context at the beginning of your
story who are they where are they what's
going on
um well there are four thomas brothers
um norman thomas was the oldest he um
he all brothers went to princeton they
lived actually
had pretty much the same background they
were the son of a presbyterian minister
who was pretty conservative in his ways
although very much of the widespread
progressive ethos that held that times
were getting better and
norman went to princeton where he loved
debate
he knew woodrow wilson theirs his
college president professor
took every class he could with woodrow
wilson um afterwards he became a
minister um
he actually went to work in the
tenements on spring in spring street
just right across the island
where he was
exposed to some
pretty extreme degradation um
although that's not really what
radicalized him that was very much there
was this movement at the time called the
social gospel movement
which held basically that
the point of
christianity was not just to enter
heaven but to establish a kingdom of god
on earth
and this was very much mainline
protestant thinking um so
tons of young men coming out of
you know
you know the kind of middle class and
um
streamed into the tenements and sort of
thought that they're they were obligated
to try and make the world a better place
um
he then he goes to union theological
seminary which is a pretty liberal
um seminary thus
crushing his father
um
and
then he goes to work at a very fancy
church on a fifth avenue
mary's a socialite
looks like he's headed towards living a
very comfortable life um
and he and his wife decide to move to
east harlem
and work in the tenements there with
mostly
italians and hungarians
um
those were the two largest immigrant
populations
um
in new york at that time
the country it was just coming off this
you know
explosion of
immigrants that come into the country i
think a third of the 92 or so million
people in 1910 that were first or second
generation americans
and
that that's when he really sort of
started to
see that
the way the country was organized was
not sustainable or just and
things needed to change
and
that was he started down that path and
the war was what pushed him
over um ralph the second brother
also went to princeton
then went to mit became an engineer
quite conservative
very happy to
you know live a good life and
be fair to others and
you know and
to his duty he was also very obsessed
with duty as most were these kind of
post-victorian victorian
young men um
but when the war began he enlisted right
away became a captain in the army
um
evan thomas the third brother was
much more tortured
he saw that there were some
he looked around him and he saw that
this kind of ameliorative efforts that
liberal christians tended to make were
you know were not doing anything and
there was a lot of hypocritical you know
self-satisfaction involved
he actually when the war broke out in
europe went to study in scotland and was
exposed to conscious objection movement
there
came back over to be a conscious
objector when the united states entered
the war
and
you know constantly had to push the
boundary
of what was acceptable in order to to
show that he was being true to himself
and true to his principles and fighting
for freedom and keeping some kind of
life or liberty alive
um
and then the youngest arthur was a lot
less sure of what to do um he
struggled at princeton kind of didn't
know what he wanted to do thought about
being a farmer
thought about being a missionary but you
have these three mighty oaks in front of
you it's amazing to get out of bed in
the morning yeah
it's arthur he called himself a gloom on
occasion
i mean his mother wants cinnamon lettuce
what why do you think that there's no
place for prince in princeton for a boy
such as you
um
and he he was not so sure the world was
such a good idea but he was also not
ready to go to prison to protest it
right so he's a lot more like i think
most of us
and there must have been a mama
there was and she was pretty
extraordinary she had her own pretty
extraordinary past she had grown up in
siam as the daughter of missionaries and
then
her father had been the first president
one of the first all black colleges in
the reconstruction south
um
but then she lived gone on to marry a
minister and had a very conventional
life in ohio with a
big brood of kids and
involved in sort of church causes but
she was actually one of part of the
she was maybe the most interesting
person to me in some ways because
she really struggled to negotiate
between our children even as
her views were being challenged by them
[Music]
so talk about norman in
walk us through
the
real crises that the brothers faced
as the question of service
was engaged
um
norman became a pacifist at the end of
1916 so right before the united states
entered the war and he became involved
in some
um organizations anti-war organizations
um the american union against militarism
was sort of the most prominent one
and that was sort of the
very
nascent uh structure that would become
the aclu after the war
um the fellowship of reconciliation was
christian pacifist group
um and he sort of started working and
they were they went through political
channels and also kind of grassroot
organization
um
and
evan didn't believe in politics that his
brother was muddle-headed um
and he just wanted to
i mean he had a kind of a martyrdom
streak in him and
he um
he
decided to come come back to the united
states to take a stand
um
ralph really believed he was heeding
wilson's call to fight for freedom and
arthur
kind of went back and forth over whether
it was less whether it became an officer
you know and ended up joining the
he wanted to become a fighter pilot was
very adventurous adventurous he wanted
to prove himself too you know he's very
much a part of that ethos
arthur was my favorite
in all this
i identified the most with him
i don't know if you can do i want you to
read this graph okay
conscience can be a problematic notion
it's hard to say just what it is and
it's easy to see where it can become
dangerous
it can make a person too rigid or
self-righteous
it can be used to justify any action
even heinous ones a group of right-wing
germans that prefigured the nazi party
titled its newsletter givison or
conscience
it can encourage egotism and
self-absorption the moaning of hamlet or
it can seem a full speech the prattle of
polonius who said to thine own self be
true
it can encourage intolerance or it can
conflict with responsibility which
sometimes means doing what's possible
even if it's not perfectly right
so how did that wonderful
definition of conscience play out for
norman
you know it's funny um
after norman had established himself as
the leader of socialist party and run
for president a bunch of times
a sociologist named daniel bell um
wrote an essay about him or
wrote wrote a book in which he included
a discussion of norman and he uh
there's this kind of famous distinction
[Music]
between at this ethics of responsibility
and the ethics of conscience and he said
the problem with norman thomas is that
he lived his life according
he thought that the state should have an
ethics of conscience
um
i actually don't think that's really
fair i think that he was much more alert
to the kind of compromises that
a government is supposed to make and
i think that the story of the brothers
does illustrate the limits and dangers
of
thinking
too much about
you know what
how to be true to yourself instead of
you know what obligations you have to
other people and and that was something
that norman was really alive to at the
time um
right after evan had gone on a hunger
strike to protest the draft he wrote
evan a letter in which he said
you know no man lives in the citadel of
himself
you know the real challenge is
to live among other people
and
you know to fight for might in maine
you know to make sure that they have the
kind of responsible opportunities that
you have so that they too can
you know be true to themselves
and he basically had a i mean it was he
was coming out of a
uh you know a protestant
background in which
you know the sermon on the mount was
sort of the ultimate you know statement
of ethics so
it's always a balancing act you know how
do you live according to your conscience
how do you
the way they sort of dealt with it they
talked about freedom of conscience right
so
the idea of freedom of conscience is
that everybody can
everybody has the freedom to act
according to their conscious means you
can't
you know enforce your belief you can't
be a nazi basically you know um
you know but it was something that they
never were capable able to define you
can't
you know and they could never solve some
of the problems that they face but they
thought you had to engage in them
so would norman thomas's legacy be
the persistence of
a culture of freedom of conscience
or is it more specifically
one toward
what we would think of as non-violence
and
caritas
and attempting to
make gentle the life of this world
is
really avoiding violence at all costs
i am
at all costs and i'm going to come back
to that
norman did not remain a pacifist his
whole life
but um
i don't see why you also have to make a
i don't think that's an either or
statement
you know i think that he believed that
freedom of conscience meant in part
um
a repudiation of violence because what
is uh what is force if not you know
imposing your will on another person
um well there's defense there's defense
too but
you know there's that whole world war
two thing there is that whole world war
two thing and that's an interesting
question but um
i also think that um
yeah i mean he
he was involved in the civil rights
movement he was involved in
um a number of you know nuclear
disarmament
a number of causes that
i would hope speak to both
sides of the issue
and he
became a
his pacifism was suspended after pearl
harbor
i mean he sort of thought it was a moot
point at that point um
the 1930s is sort of a different
situation he um
he had seen too much of
boss hague and you know some
[Music]
kind of ugly leaders
uh not to fear fascism and in this
country and he worried that
in light of the great depression and
light of some of the egregious abuses of
civil rights that he saw
that
war in this country would lead to
would lead to fascism here i mean we
sort of hear that and kind of
can't believe that you know this is the
greatest generation they would never you
know fascism would never occur here but
that's you know he worried about that
and
no it was a lie fear
now the the one story i grew up knowing
about norman thomas is probably
apocryphal but involves a conversation
with franklin roosevelt
do you want to tell the story
sure
you knew this was coming i knew this was
john's favorite story
um
so
one of norman's uh
causes in the 1930s was um he was
working on behalf of sharecroppers in
the south who were
you know being murdered and lynched and
just
unbelievable things were happening to
them they were you know laws were being
passed in cities saying i couldn't meet
in groups and
um
there were drive-by shootings and it was
unbelievable situation um
and when they tried to unionize it got
much much worse
um and he'd gone down to the south and
he'd been ridden out of town you know by
men carrying shotguns and the whole
thing and he
was writing roosevelt letter after a
letter saying you've got to do something
you've got to do something
and he gets a meeting at the white house
and he goes
he says roosevelt you've got to do
something this is just unconscionable
and roosevelt
looks across the desk and says
you know what norman
i'm a damn slight better politician than
you are
i know these people and we've got to
wait their people are doing good work
down there and it's just going to take
some time
and norman zach
was saying
you can't you can't wait
you know i mean in a way this is a
this is what you know the response of
son pacifist
would say you can't wait you can't let
this go on that was his response to what
was happening in the south you know
ultimately you know things did change
and it did take a lot of time but
you can say like
maybe the climb in the 1930s
wouldn't allow the political climate
social climate economic climate wouldn't
allow for roosevelt to come in and the
national guard and change things you
know maybe you had to wait 30 years but
a lot of bad things happen in the south
in 30 years you know when it comes to
racial violence so
well one of the things that's
fdr's own social conscience was awakened
when
eleanor brought him to this part of new
york
uh and
insofar as he was able to project
those values domestically
how do you
[Music]
where do you come out on the issue of
the limits of politics but the demands
of justice
because no one would argue now
that
because of the failures of
reconstruction uh because of the
institution of
uh jim crow uh because of the robber
barons in the north uh in the economic
oppression
that many many social reforms should
have happened earlier many many social
reforms that should happen right now
will not
because there's another man in the white
house who also believes he's a damn site
a better politician than anyone who
wanders in that tends to be an
occupational hazard for people behind
that desk
how do where do you come out is this
just the tragedy of history or are there
moments where
individuals do make this difference
well eleanor herself you know she like
to say that she if she weren't married
to the man in the white house she would
have voted for norman thomas so
um
i think she's one of the individuals who
made a difference actually i and i think
fdr was too
um and maybe norman thomas was too you
know if if she was right that
he was part of
he was pushing her and she was pushing
him and
i think it's much more organic um
than
you know
you can never
point to someone and say here's the
difference
um
but i do think that
politics is messy we make painful
compromises all the time
um
you know nothing works according to plan
and uh everything has its limits i mean
i think that
evan thomas the conscious objector
he at one point got into a fight with
norman about politics he said norma i
don't understand these political moves
you're making don't you understand that
the state has to respond as the state is
going to respond you know the president
has a democracy you have a
responsibility to you know re act
according to the popular majority
you know your moves are muddle-headed
and norman's sort of stiffly and
unconvincingly wrote back you know we're
not muddle-headed
we're doing all sorts of things
um
you know do i think that uh
norman was an effective socialist
or effective politician as a socialist i
think it was
not a i think fdr was right he was a
damn site better politician than norman
do i think there was a place for norman
you know in the american political
political system yeah
absolutely do i think that there should
be
maybe more of those
i think so i mean i think that
um
the health of the democracy you know
requires a kind of open exchange of
ideas and
um
the kind of battles that he and norman
and his uh
his friends during world war faced about
do you reform from the inside or the
outside do you try and get a seat at the
table you know do you
what is the best way to
to get your point across your message
across to
do justice um
are ones that we still face we just
maybe aren't as noisy about them as
people once were
well that's a question i wanted to ask
you about
generational responsibility
do you think that your
great-grandfather's
generation
did the media and political
landscape
give him a bigger voice
as a
socialist candidate as a figure
almost always of dissent
then
we currently are able for whatever
reason to
give voices outside the mainstream
or
what does the
you know your generation uh has created
this thing called the interweb
and
is that uh gonna open this up
well i mean i think it's a
the internet is opening it up and also
drawing it out so i mean it's hard to
it's hard to say for sure um
i do think that uh
the
you know the american political system
doesn't
uh allow for their third parties very
easily it actually did a little bit more
so in norman's time because
uh
socialism
was a viable idea actually in 1912.
eugene dubs got six percent of the vote
um now if anyone called himself a social
sub
[Music]
you know
you you know be considered evil actually
a nazi or whatever
um or the recipient of a wall street
bailout or the recipient of a wall
street bailout
um
so
yeah i mean i think that there's a
little bit more
generational complacency
than there was in his
in his generation
maybe because
you know we don't have to go to war
maybe because
it was just a smaller world
you know you could get access to the
president yeah you know you could
you knew reporter i mean it was just an
easier to but to challenge that baby
it was smaller but
we now know
we now know the things you don't want
out
certainly have a tendency to get out
why isn't there
in this highly educated
highly affluent
generation uh of which you remember
a higher level of
social
engagement in a way that we would
recognize as a
taminzian level uh from the early part
of the century
i think there are people who say that
there
is more than you know more than meets
the eye i mean i think that
you can make the argument that peop
people are involved in kind of community
projects um
you know to a degree that is
you know
as much i mean they might not be
interested in getting to politics but
they're interested in you know starting
companies that might you know have
renewable energy
impacts or
things like that um
which have sort of like
social social ends
um
i think that that your
one of your early questions is is part
of the answer there's not a kind of
demand um upon my generation
that there once was there's no draft
um even taxes are not very high you know
there's not
uh not very much is asked of us um i
mean in a way we're sort of reverting
back to like your only interaction with
the federal government is
the post office you know the dmv your
passport which is not even federal
government your passport yeah right
um
so
i mean i i don't think this is you know
i don't
i'm not saying we should have a draft
again you know
i think we should okay well it's a
different debate but um
that's actually an interesting debate i
think you know i think there's
a compelling argument to me made for it
i mean i think that the uh
you know we ask a lot of of our um
of our servicemen and i think that you
know
the recruitment process is
kind of gnarly um you know they're
i think that there should be more
uh
equitable sacrifice made across the
population well reading the reason i
bring this up is reading the book
i kept coming back to
hear these brothers
in a cult thoroughly engaged electrified
political time
projection of force
a president who had trouble with
congress but who managed to suspend
civil liberties and get his way this
sounds somewhat familiar
but
one difference that kept coming back to
my mind was
because there is not a draft because
there is not the possibility
that the upper middle class
can be
in harm's way
then
it all becomes slightly academic
i i just submit that if we had what are
approaches of vietnam era draft
with all the exceptions where you could
serve nationally at home as opposed to
militaristically militarily all that
if that happened is there anyone who
plausibly believes we would have been in
iraq past 2004 or we would still be in
afghanistan
i don't think it's alright it's arguable
i mean that's why i just said i think
this is a debate that we can actually
have you know because i think it's
you know you can make an argument for it
uh at the same time i
it's just it is a kind of academic
question i just don't think it's gonna
happen but your grandfather would say we
have to have these academic arguments we
do have to have these academic arguments
maybe but um
don't go playing fdr on me
i know i'm a damn sight better
something um
yeah you know
i think that one of the things to
remember about these brothers and one of
the reasons why i think looking at their
stories really valuable is that they
were really
working out how to answer some of these
questions and there was an urgency
because they were new questions
they felt them
you know and these are questions that we
just don't
feel you know the kind of
uh tension between you know your
responsibilities individual
your responsibility as a citizen ethics
versus morality i mean these are these
all sound academic terms but like when
it came down to it it's like
are you gonna die for your country you
know are you going to uh
change society in such a way that
you know it's not as
unequal it's not as unjust i mean
sweetheart we have these huge structural
problems in this country you know
i think our poverty rate among children
is like 22 second in mexico
you know it's just
um
there's some really really big things
going on and they're not
questions that most of us wake up and
think about i certainly don't and i
don't have to you know it's
it's um
i i fee i'm lucky
you know i don't i'm lucky that i get to
live my life and pursue my opportunities
and
um
you know do what i want to do but it's
not the case
for everyone so
well i bring this up because i i find
the book a compelling
this book raises these issues in a
compelling and implicit way
which is a very difficult thing to do uh
and
i think anyone reading it now will find
quite resonant everything that's going
on and unfolding around the
the news now and and forever more uh i'm
gonna ask you to read this and then we
want to take some questions from you all
uh
your pen ultimate graph here
read that through the quotation of the
letter
right or wrong he loved his family
in 1941 while norman was still publicly
speaking out against the united states
entry into world war ii his son evan
welling thomas ii
volunteered to drive ambulances for the
british
just before he shipped out november 1941
norman sent
him a letter
in a cruel and ugly world you've never
made
you made choices you've made you've
chosen what is for you i'm sure the best
possible course he wrote
more than i can tell you we shall be
missing you and loving you and wishing
for the external good fortune and still
more for the inner courage and hope
which may sustain you despite our
follies and the madness of men are made
for better things and constant
exploitation and ever-recurring wars it
will be great happiness always to carry
your watch till you return to claim it
evan willing thomas ii was my
grandfather and i have that watch now
it is a reminder of more than a father's
love for his family it is more too than
a young man's desire to fight for
freedom it is a reminder that norman's
conscience was not the nation's it was
his own that lesson he had learned long
before
the book is conscience louisa thomas
thank you
[Applause]
now we have
instructions
which you must follow conscientiously
stuck here
so if people have questions they can
just come right up here for them
this gentleman has been taking notes so
this that's never a good sign
could you talk about norman's
inspiration and all by the work of john
reed
sure well john reed um
john raised more
norm became a socialist in 1918.
um john reid
something that we haven't mentioned at
all was there was a russian revolution
that happened in 1917.
um
and uh
john reed like
many um liberals across the world
um
was hugely inspired by this uh norman
was too um so was walter lipman and and
so was
woodrow wilson you know in woodrow
wilson's uh
war address you know he said that
basically how we treat russia will be to
ask the test of our democracy
um
i think
uh
norman became a norman was not
kind of as inspired by the
utopian project as john reed was um
i didn't consider himself a marxist
um
in fact when he applied for the
socialist party he wrote a long letter
um explaining why
he was really kind of
uh not totally for the socialist party
and apparently you have these success uh
yeah so she knows that spyro living in
the midwest i'd be non-partisan league
and you know i fear that the socialist
party is not always respected civil
liberties and
um i'm not a marxist and um
you know i really fear any state whether
democratic or whether capitalistic or
socialistic that um claims to have any
control over the
you know the minds and work of men
and um
he sent this letter off and his
application was actually returned to him
because
uh he had not filled up the other side
with his practical information
um so i think that he
i actually
if he knew john reed i don't know um in
this in this point in time
um
but certainly he knew people like max
eastman
um
other socialists or scott nearing
um
you know other people who are
uh
kind of part of that
part of that milieu and circle i mean
read story is is
tragic in its own way um
and because of norman's story was
was different he followed a different
path but
um to what extent that the slaughter
that had been going on in europe for the
past three years especially for evan who
had been over in scotland what extended
that influence what he and norman
thought as opposed to what ralph and
arthur sure i mean it was huge i mean um
uh
world war one was just
unbelievable i mean
1.8 million germans 1.7 million russians
1.4 million frenchmen
i mean just
the the deaths you know just astonished
even in the us you know the u.s lost
about 50 000 but
really the fighting only lasted for six
months they were losing something like
820 men a day i mean that's just
unbelievable um
you know evan he was over in uh scotland
and then also in london a little bit and
um
you know he saw he saw what it was like
to you know see men come home without
limbs and things like that um
and and also what it was like to be in
london when the bombs are falling um
but
every man responds to violence and
every culture responds to violence in
different ways
ralph was actually wounded
um on the western front and you know
recuperated in these hospitals but
um he remained uh
he remained proud of what he died and
did and thought that it was the right
thing and until until the end of the war
he wasn't disillusioned
so um
you know i think that
um
they were well aware of how
devastating the violence was but i don't
think it predictably you know drove them
in one way or the other but
the extremity of the violence is one of
the reasons why they thought they had to
be fighting for something greater
and that was true in every country it
was one of the reasons it had to be
a kind of it would only be a just war
and the loss of life would only be
justified if
something so great could emerge from
this inferno
um
and that's also why you know one of the
reasons why it was so hard
to give it out you know
you know it's just
appalling
anything else
nope
hey louisa
um
actually to sort of jump right off what
you just said i'm curious how much the
civil war was in the imagination of
these brothers especially given the fact
that their mother was as you said was on
in south
as i'm assuming with whether or not her
own parents were abolitionists or not
but i think of these brothers and if
like this had been the 1840s or 50s you
sort of patrician northern elites and
and very involved in like protestant and
ideas of morality within that protestant
church that they would have been the
robert gold shaws right i mean they
would have been sort of almost like
leading the brigades in certain ways um
and so
your point that
if if this much violence is only worth
it there's some like higher moral cause
let's say like emancipation i mean
obviously they don't see that in world
war one do they talk about the civil war
as a war that might have been worth it
is it in their consciousness at all um
the anti-war movement that pacifist
movement that evan and norman were
involved in they drew really heavily on
the example of the abolitionists and
they were trying to eradicate war in the
same way that um
you know slavery had once been
eradicated
um
and
they said you know that once that had
said people had said that reform would
be gradual that would be impossible
whatever and they said no look this this
happened
war two can be eradicated um and war is
a kind of slavery in its own way
um
and they absolutely saw themselves as
the inheritors of that tradition
um
you know the civil war
it's interesting because this is the
civil war is only really a generation or
two away you know in this time and there
was this uh congressman isaac sherwood
who stood up and you know during the
debate over whether or not to go to war
he said i've seen
he had been in the civil war and he said
i've seen war
we cannot go to war
um but
you know i think there are other there
are certain historians would say every
generation fights its own war you know
so
that's sort of
anything else
again louisa thank you the book is
conscious
[Applause]
this event was hosted by the tenement
museum in new york city to find out more
visit tenement.org
today on book tv's in depth author
activist and chickasaw nation
writer-in-residence lin